[Musique]
c'était hier sous le grand carbet du
parc aimé césaire la cgtm soem c'est le
point sur les différentes actions
qu'elle ne doit pas perdre de vue
parmi elles la réforme des retraites qui
fait débat scandale et grève depuis le 5
décembre 2019
quasi tous les syndicats sont deux
consoeurs il n'est pas question qu'ils
abandonnent la mobilisation collège dix
et quelques écoles primaires sont
fermées depuis près de deux mois
la loi ne prévoit pas de rémunération
pour les grévistes alors de quoi vivent
t-il sa vrai que nous déposons un
préavis de rire mais nous rejoindra
tiendront tous les matins dans les lieux
de travail mais malheureusement fait
matraquer un syndicat main mais tous les
matins les collègues et moi nous sommes
sur notre lieu de travail
il devrait pas y avoir d'incidence sur
d'autres saluent le wall février tous
les portails des collèges et lycées sont
effectivement bien par icade et les
personnels interrogés sont tous nos
grévistes leurs salaires seront donc
versés normalement pour l'éducation
nationale les règles sont identiques
une journée de grève correspond à une
suspension du contrat de travail
donc pas de salaire les jours de grève
mais selon la secrétaire générale devait
se unsa leur administration présenterait
un document particulier que certains
salariés ont fini dans le premier degré
il y a les déclarations d'intention
nous avons une obligation
le faire savoir à l'administration notre
intention je dis bien notre intention de
faire grève ou pas et se trouvait ce qui
est aussi que nous avons dénoncé ce que
hocine acceptable c'est que le rectorat
a fait des fonctions salaires simplement
se basant sur les déclarations
d'intention et ça c'est inacceptable
l'avons déjà dénoncé négociations du
paiement des jours de grève
étalement de la dette du salarié
certaines faveurs peuvent être accordées
dans la fonction publique
mais qu'en est il des entreprises
privées légalement le travailleur qui
cessent de travailler qu'ils cessent
totalement de travailler n'est pas payé
mais le non paiement est au prorata du
nombre d'heures non travail il est
totalement illégal de lui enlever +2
qu'il ne faut s'est adouci majorité
travaille deux heures son continent les
moins deux jours alors finalement la loi
sur le paiement des jours de grève est
quasi la même pour tous les secteurs
mais curieusement presque tous les
personnels des établissements scolaires
fermés sont rémunérés nous on a très peu
d'agents en grève les agents sont là
devant les devants les écoles bloqués
ils pointent donc on n'a pas dit qui est
des agents municipaux en grève
il y avait le pointage enfin vous êtes
un potage ou pas oui on fait des
pointages de chaque matin pour nos
agents agents des collectivités
personnels de l'éducation nationale qui
bloque les écoles la question reste
entière